this is a production of Cornell
University
okay so my talk today is about
understanding the genetic architecture
of quantitative traits and this endless
quest that we have to try and understand
quantitative traits and whether it's
really pretty cool in terms of plant
breeding and I'm going to build my time
and industry and finish up with telling
you something about Cobie project so my
PhD I was incredibly lucky I had perfect
project mildew in India and pearl millet
is just an incredible crop has these
beautiful long panicles late in the
pear-shaped seeds and it can be popped
like popcorn it also has a higher
nutrient content and most importantly it
can withstand long periods of no
rainfall and then when it rains it's
really an amazing crop and it was also a
success with the Green Revolution there
were several there were two male sterile
lines produced in Tifton Georgia in the
US and with those they started to
produce hybrids and those hybrids were
very successful and were widely accepted
and we've spread all over India when the
first several domains Fanny Mills you
made that epidemics occurred causing a
massive loss in yields from 13 3 million
metric tons in a single year so
the disease is caused by a pathogen
called cross for a grammar Nicola it's
an O my seat another goodbye a truth and
resistance is quantitative so you see a
continuous distribution you screen for
resistance but it's also environmentally
variable so there's obviously some
either environmental differences or
population very little was known about
the disease then very few single Zeus
for isolates and no differentials are
being characterized but it's a really
amazing pathogen instead of growing into
the leaf and forming a local lesion what
it actually does is it grows down to the
growing point of the plant
half leaves this one and this part was
differentiated so you get these half
leaf symptoms showing infections
infection you get this really wild panic
so my project was to Matt qtls for
resistance pearl millet and because of
quarantine restrictions they couldn't
take pathogens from parts of Africa and
parts then deer are moving to another
location too
they were very strictly would not
allowed to move any of those diseased
plants and my supervisor was in India at
the time he was working at a Cossack
which is the International merits that's
what they were working on which was a
little crazy because the place he chose
in the UK was North Wales which is the
rainiest place in the UK it's if you
think seattle is rainy it's like three
or four times one of the rainiest places
in the world but surprisingly pearl
millet liked it grew pretty well that's
me doing Danny mildew screens in Bangor
in Wales in the UK and we also rep
and so cut a long story short this was
the essence of the results pearl millet
has seven linkage groups and each of
these graphs is a separate linkage group
and with the different color lines
different pathogen populations on the
y-axis is the log of the odds ratio LOD
score with a special about two and also
some key tales of minor effect like you
see on and the amazing thing was those
qtls were extremely stable over repeated
screens different disease pressures and
I did carry on to try and isolate single
populations and found even more so a
huge amount of a Burlinson and a huge
amount of resistance in permanent
materials so this was a real story there
was a very popular hybrid called hhp
disease and by integrating one of these
Danny mildew resistances into hhp beasts
of 67 we could make it resistance now
how long in that kind of environment can
you have a resistance last probably two
to three years and the pearl millet
breeders have actually been very clever
they've diversified their parental
materials that going into hybrids they
interest new resistance genes over time
and they've stacked resistance genes and
so in this very diverse host-pathogen
environment where easily they could have
had continuous epidemics they've managed
to keep increasing yields
a great success story but then this is
what I find is more typically the case
is that the project I worked on with
late light resistance and the late
lights caused by fight or infest and
Irish potato famine of 1845 and
immigration resistance last two three
years in potatoes they tend to look for
general resistance so many many q two
L's of small effect and so that's what
we try to do in tomato too so we were
working with UC riverside this is a
project at UC Davis with I'll just call
my coffee he'd found this wild tomato
line that was resistant by tougher
infestations and forgive me I forget the
names wrong because I changed their
names to species for tomato so what was
her suitum is now so this shows the wild
species completely clean no disease did
bidirectional backcrosses and in by
directional and this was the results of
this study I'm just showing sometimes
the QTL would overlap but the peaks are
not necessarily distinct the peaks are
these little triangles here this is
esculenta genetic map on the left and
the hirsute him on the right the more we
screened the more cutie else we found
the more confused we were with what we
were going to do with this and what
we're finding because we were also
mapping application
probably a big mistake to be mapping in
but esculenta more like a per second is
this nice compact bushy plant and her
suitum is this horrible wieldy rambling
indeterminant plant so basically what we
ended up mapping was a lot of cutie ELLs
for plan architecture and canopy the
more open the canopy is they're less
disease the less humid it is and the
less disease is built up but we did
because oh this was one of the qtls that
I was particularly excited about and I
really wanted to see where this QTL went
so QTL for dispersal so this is the
cultivated parent and you can just see
the little droplet this is also after
inoculation and just disappears it's
like magic just disappears into the leaf
and that's thought to be due to the
different tricone differences so we
definitely pursued this QTL and this was
the end result and this is a lot to take
in but each of these mini blocks is
basically a set of introgression lines
and so we're just showing four different
qtls here and the cutie ELLs are in red
and so for example this line markers
which are amplified
but when screening but we just didn't
have anything we could QTL were all
co-located with some on the germplasm
such as plant height shape maturity
yield and none of these were usable in
plant breeding sense and it was
published which is good results as well
but in terms of being so I'd had several
of these projects where I was getting
increasingly frustrated with being able
to move QTL into cultivated plasm being
able to move them into breeding programs
and I was kind of sick of just
collecting QTL never going anywhere I'm
pretty sure industry has the answer so I
was recruited to industry they have lots
of money they have systems and again I
was disappointed issues that we had an
industry corn
I mean Mazin soybean was the parents are
extremely cycles extremely fast to the
breeding process you cross your parents
you make your selections you can
constantly shifting that curve for yield
and moving it towards higher yields and
as soon as you have those selections
from the progeny bales become the new
parents in there they're using old
parents again and again it's always new
parents going into that breeding cycle
and that's how you make quickly
and if you had a QTL you mat QTL you
really have to slow down breeding cycle
and you remember they're also
interesting transgenes
so they're trying to manage and
association mapping was it were a couple
of groups working on associate
association nothing even less because
don't contain elite lines don't contain
lines of high relevance to breeding
population and so even if a QTL is found
the answer Jean Luc's papers up here is
to be able to map qtls and in the actual
breeding population it might be small
but you can use pedigree information and
you can use shared haplotypes to be able
to map as you're breeding so you're not
mapping details in separate populations
and then bringing the QTA you're doing
it actually in the breeding populations
and there was a second method it was
very popular in the soybean breeding
program called breeding bias and
basically that just looked at the very
very simple look to the alleles and
ancestral populations and the alleles
and elite populations those increase in
frequency breeders had selected from
them breed as a GERD so they must be
good and so that was the premise
over time we had so many of these many
of them were closely linked or had
closely linked with positive and
negative alleles actually had so it
really became too much information and
as I think about how we were handling
these like QTL would pop up from one
generation where the QTL is and I
apologize for this next slide I think
this is like what I imagine it's like
serious representation qtls illustrates
it very nicely breeding programs this is
a stole from Roberta tuberosa to quote
it says forgiving QTL no or negative
effects depending on the scenario in
this case it was drought this
complication has slowed considerably of
the utilization of DNA breeding quality
of QTL so you can imagine that everyone
was extremely excited when genomic
selection came on the scene and started
to make waves and we started to see that
we could make a real impact with genomic
selection
doesn't try and understand the
underlying genes of quantitative trait
trait so you have your training
population which is being phenotype and
genotype and that's used to train your
breeding material which is only saves
you a huge amount of money to just
genotype it calculate what's called a
gbb or genetic estimated values and make
selections based on those values and
it's really what is going to take
and John Hickey he's a quantitative
geneticist at the Roslin Institute has a
nice quote he feels like molecular
biologist took over plant breeding it
used to be the domain of quantitative
genetics and all these QTL were suddenly
molecular geneticists were the ones that
were running plant breeding and now with
genomic selection
I'm breeding back into the wrong arms
and you can see it for some of the very
visible products that pioneer has had
they bred drought-tolerant corn some
seminars here on this a product called a
series of products called aqua max where
they're using genomic selection to
well-watered conditions and high yield
under drought conditions and so you see
aqua max products at these green squares
which have very high yields and the
drought conditions and most
interestingly these pre-k was working in
markers and this shows the number of
snips needed to give a good prediction
accuracy in European corn and I think
this was some diluting design and so at
about 300 markers you've pretty much got
a plateau for your prediction accuracy
there's no need you can imagine in a
maze double haploid breeding population
going to be even fewer markers that
you're going to need
the type of technology was a challenge
to begin with had to be low cost and low
cost as an equal to the cost of a corn
flux or less or soybean plot which is
about five dollars and has to be Ray
robust high percentage whether you've
got horrible samples coming in from some
part of the world or really bad do you
make them really stable across different
conditions you have to have a consistent
because of the turnaround time you can't
be imputing data you can't be messing
around trying to match up with different
market sets markers in them breeders
really like to add their own trace and
one important key just to mention here
because industry went into took a foray
into sequencing GPS technologies lo
sequence coverage technologies and just
found by informatics was too expensive
and too time-consuming to be able to
handle so they really needed matrix with
a very fast turnaround time technologies
in this space not sure what they're
called now but they used to be called
their next-generation genotyping or
targeted sequencing technologies so
these are like in-between sequencing and
genotyping technologies we have specific
primers and probes that can be amplicon
based on like aged face and everything
just goes into one big bucket and is
amplified at once and the samples are
bar coded so you could distinguish
between them and the most popular one
right now is technology's been looking
at with high DT and that's really low
cost and also highly multiplexed so if
you look at the turnaround time that we
were dealing with maize that will have
food production after you doubled your
material
you had about two weeks for
transplanting and the more data you
could get back before transplanting the
better because transplanting was
extremely expensive so they want to be
able to get back within two weeks so
that was about a data sample and that's
not a few samples that's tens of
thousands of samples in that one day
about a day for DNA extraction maybe two
days shipping two days living data and
doing a collection analysis they left
five five days to get your genotyping
dates back so those are the kind of
timelines we have to meet in the double
haploid scenario
and so genotyping came about science
more about running logistics what steps
can i co-locate I've got my double hi
Floyd lab in the middle of South America
with very limited workforce where do I
put my DNA prep lab I can't put it next
to my double haploid lab because I'm
probably gonna fail so now I have to
have an ID in the extraction lab
separate to that and in those days
vendors didn't want to mess around with
plant DNA extractions and so he pretty
much had two steps of shipping from
double haploids to DNA extraction to
your genotyping lab so you really had to
have end to end the biggest risk and
this whole thing became shipping and
customs and understanding which
countries would tolerate important
exports so meanwhile back in the
developing developing countries this
graph from the Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation shows increases in yield
between 61 and you can see the US and
India had some increase but not very
much and Africa is actually pretty flat
it's not significantly different over
all of that time almost 60 years so this
is the Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation
decided that one of the solutions that
this was to start implementing genomic
selection in the breeding programs that
support these countries and so that's
where Kobe was born and this the goal of
this project is transform reading by
enabling
the implementation of genomic a marker
assisted selection by routine there are
main goals was build databases to
connect to breeding management systems
and to build and connect tools and
analysis pipelines and we're a global
community we are based here at Cornell
and also at the Boyce Thompson Institute
down the road and we collaborate with
three different cities simit which is a
Mexico maize and wheat eco set in India
for sorghum and chickpeas working back
and airy in the Philippines where we
work with brace institute tool
development and we've built within this
community and extract data the client
the system into the system we store in
two different directions directions and
whole thing is built in industry some
base
marking tests so we have some test data
sets 5,000 samples 32 million markers
and this shows different databases that
were and it's even better than some
we're handling
again for extracting this just shows
increasing sizes of data and extracting
them different information we are also
developing tools most importantly a
genomics we have open source tools in a
tool called flapjack which is a candy
bar in the UK and that's to visualize
the data and then we're working with
pinned up to be able to do the analytics
system how do we tie this and we're
working with crappy which is a breeding
and pizzelle be who runs this community
is based here at Cornell and also at BT
I and reports and we're running this
under the excellence of breeding
platform this is a new platform that the
CG centers have funded from the villa
Melinda Gates to be able to consolidate
a lot of this research across the CG
centers and Kelly Robbins is leading
module five in that platform so we're
all about community and collaboration we
have members that go be within each of
the Institute's that we work with we do
a lot of training and cross-training
we also really strive to work very
closely with neighboring projects and
resources so let's look again at what is
needed to be able to do genomic
selection well and how well we are doing
in being able to implement genomic
selection these are the components that
we need reading management
high-throughput sampling and shipping
genotyping platform data management high
throughput analysis and api's the market
assisted selection you can get away with
just an Excel spreadsheet but if you
missed a genomic selection and this is
the state status in industry they have
invested over many years and all of
these systems a huge amount of resources
that have been filled tens of years they
pretty much got everything in place and
they're still finding it hard
implement genomic selection it's not
easy for them and then in the CG centers
we're suffering from little bits of
money here and there one project to
their system one project for another
system CG centers are not not all about
plant breeding they are there for the
greater good they're there to be able to
support the local communities and
sustain resources so plant breeding is
only just a part of what they do and
they don't have many resources and those
resources are spread across multiple
projects with multiple objectives so
again excellence in breeding is trying
to focus these resources to develop
sustainable solutions
and we need to get our ducks in a row
for those systems because coming down
the road is a whole new suite of
technologies in terms of data analytics
and artificial intelligence on the farm
I just think it's amazing all of these
companies that are currently active in
this space there's gonna be a lot of
venture capital around to be able to
support this many companies very highly
saturated market precision analytics or
hybrid on the farm understanding your
marketplaces robotics and Jones sensors
smart irrigation based your AI
technology but we're also seeing a lot
of new information coming out of allele
mining where you look at the diversity
of alleles across across your species
and try and track them to a particular
geographic location or particular
phenotype and you can use that also to
understand your trades edit the DNA and
inject the mutation that we want and
we're seeing multiplex mutations it's
not very reliable yet but I'm sure it
will be soon and so now we can take all
of the information that we get through
AAA and Big Data and the lil mining and
Landscaping of reading in the future and
I'd say also I actually worked in IP
when I was at pioneer for eight years I
know I was there and this is really
gonna change how IP lawyers and in the
era of genomics data they're really I
mean in genomics and genomic selection
there really wasn't a lot patent you
didn't have any unique sequences there
were method patents for the genomic
selection methodologies and there's
rampant method patents are hard to
police plant patents are only available
in the US I can just see these IP
lawyers salivating CRISPR with a
function that can be used to patent
materials globally and also that are
easy to please because you've got all
those sequences there I can just see a
sequence so that'd make my advanced add
slides I've stolen this one and so he
talks about reading 1.0 in a typical
selection controlled traits 2.0 with
qtls we're here genomic selection and
3.0 and it's really gonna change how we
do plant breeding in terms of discovery
but I believe that no matter how many
tools you have to be able to elucidate
during complexes and understand those
gene complexes using all this AAA and
machine learning we're still going to
struggle to be able to move those genes
into breeding material to keep up with
the parents election cycle unless we can
have CRISPR technologies that can
instantaneously mutate lines as they go
through that breeding cycle or unless
those traits are of extremely high value
the value of that continuous breeding
cycle is just not going to allow those
new cutie ELLs and however much we know
so I really think it's going to be a
combination of and that's because
biology isn't easy but more we look at
genetics and so we can have these new
tools and we can try and delve down into
the rabbit hole of that complexity but
in the end
[Applause]
how long we think the public
soo-ji centers are going to be able to
catch up here with industry I don't
think we'll ever catch up with industry
I think we have to and I would say to
turn all of these faces Hunter is trying
to address that issue you mentioned
foundation because as sure that breeding
programs only have small markets our
project and wondering how for a fitting
we have to address the yield stagnation
problem but it's certainly not the only
component yield stagnation nitrogen
right that's another project that Gates
Foundation is funding and also security
is a massive issue in Africa the seed is
either counterfeit seed or it's just the
wrong cross was accidentally made it's
very very high rate just bad
and so by putting in seed purity quality
mechanisms which we're helping to do
through our project that's going to make
huge advances just by itself and
improving yields and then genomic
selection to make that happen
and microsystem selection can also
we spend a lot of time going out in the
CG systems testing it to see if it's
scalable right now we'll be sailing it
right now we're building so one question
about the environments because a lot of
the breeding happens with giving climate
in soils and so a lot of you know when
we think about technologies being adult
in different countries and we think of
those transfers are in a genetic
material going from one place to another
one we don't necessarily control for the
environment in the other location so how
is the environment dealt with in this
system and you know how my question make
sense that is that clear enough
[Music]
that's handled by the plant breeders in
the CG centers to understand those
environments and where they need to be
testing materials in and any
environmental variation will become part
of the model of genomic selection as
well climate change so that was like I'm
on a follow-up question so how is that
is this are these systems accounting for
that or is there a way that that can
come in through this relay - or they
kind of myopic in that sense all right
system right now in the environments
that they are in but drought tolerance
salinity tolerance very important traits
as well thank you as well as yield as
Pat fires predicting for the future
changes in environment I'm sure modeling
could have a role in that space to be
able to incorporate that into future
models experimental design it's very
simple to implement
that is um thank you oh I was wondering
if you could speak a little bit more
about how you mentioned crisper will be
integrated into the building project if
there's less emphasis on understanding a
machine architecture and the underlying
change that you need to really
understand the sequences to be fully
utilized right CRISPR is not but CRISPR
is very much being incorporated and
prioritized in industry breeding
programs because of the patent
protection that it gives it wasn't part
of your talk tonight it was separate
from thank you this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu